Business Insider for those who don't
know is one of the leading business
publications online it's backed by a
number of major venture firms including
our re institutional venture partners
and many other is the site attracts over
25 million viewers a month and i'm sure
that number is fast out of date but i
want to welcome them on stage so we can
have a great in about Silicon Alley and
its growth as well as business insider
itself so please join me welcome to on
stage
Maicon we stay up no I'm just going to
stay in for a sec you sit down hey folks
at the back I have a favor there are
plenty of seats if you're going to sit
please come in now and sit down fill up
some seeds if you're not going to sit if
you could stop the chatter at the back
it's a little distracting for the people
in the back row right you guys yeah okay
we're going to spend the next 40 minutes
and it's going to be pretty exciting i
wish we had more time but Henry has such
a long history we've got a lot to cover
we're going to try and cover the early
years pretty quickly and then focus more
on Business Insider but before we start
I would like to clarify that Victor said
Business Insider does not have 25
million uniques a month 70 70 biggest
pub business publication in the world
much bigger than the wall street journal
man yeah number one and we'll get into
that in a second my role for the next 40
minutes is to be Charlie Rose so I'm not
Jonathan bulkley i am charlie rose well
so don't call me Charlie okay last night
I saw that amazon announced earnings and
for the first time they broke out AWS
and for those that don't know Henry
started his career with the Amazon
projection so I really wanted to start
with that because it broke through 400
bucks a share which split-adjusted I'm
not quite sure what it is 66 yeah but
it's a hundred and eighty billion
dollars and in 1998 17 years ago you
made a prediction and that prediction
has led you here today so I'd like to
start with that moment when you penned
the first amazon piece great so first
let me just say it's a huge privilege to
be here thank you and I hope it will be
interesting and I assume we have a QA
somebody like that that'd be great ask
ask anything just a quick snapshot in
case jonathan has assumed that you know
heard some things about Maisie oh I
graduated from Yale in 88 I spent a year
teaching in japan I came back I was a
journalist and a writer for about three
to five years it was teaching tennis to
pay for that I came to New York i worked
at CNN audubon Harper's a few other
places in my late 20s I decided to go
into the
finance industry went through an
investment banking training program
ultimately became an analyst which is
sort of a hybrid of journalism and
banking and was the right place for me
within that industry started that the
internet came along it created 30 empty
chairs in research departments where
people needed to follow the internet if
you've got a browser a few days ahead of
the rest of the people on your floor you
were suddenly the internet expert so I
had been in tech banking so it's a good
fit got sucked into that was an Internet
analyst for a little while and then made
a a call that got a lot more attention
that I certainly thought it would when I
made the call which jonathan is
referring to but let me take you through
the quick snapshot so I went on I was
working to the smaller firm i went to
merrill lynch it was there for three
years was very much in the news as an
internet analyst then when the market
crashed i also got caught up in the big
regulatory backlash the van Attorney
General of New York Eliot Spitzer went
through my emails and found some emails
that he found particularly exciting and
scandalous and he publicly keelhauled me
in front of the world and I got kicked
out of the securities industry basically
the allegation was you said some things
in email that showed the true thing that
you think about a company and the report
didn't have the exact language in it so
obviously the report was misleading I
pleaded my case which was we weren't
allowed to say piece of junk in the
report that's an SEC regulation but you
can say that an email doesn't mean the
stocks not going to go up that fell on
deaf ears was our junk yes piece of junk
was one of the famous emails if you
googled me piece of junk up it will come
on a stock by the way that had dropped
93% of that point I was I thought
describing the situation fairly
accurately it was self-evidently a piece
of junk it had gone down 93% I'm but
anyway we'll talk about that we want so
I got booted out of the securities
industry and then went back into
journalism which was basically the only
thing that I could still do I didn't
think that anyone would ever employ me I
called an editor friend of mine I said
ah larissa at The New Yorker is there
anyone in New York that would publish me
given that I have been so thoroughly
flogged and she said I know just the
person and editor of slate jacob
weisberg said come on board and so I
came on board I wrote that I did a lot
of freelance stuff started writing a
blog and then in 2007 it's actually
called by another Yale graduate Kevin
Ryan who had been the CEO of
double-click during the whole boom that
I had gotten to know him he said look
thinking about starting a tech
publication in New York and digital like
a techcrunch for New York what do you
think met with Kevin we decided we have
on to found this company that was
silicon alley insider which we started
in 2007 has just evolved over eight
years into quick business insider and
then much bigger and now digital
publishing in general and as Jonathan
was kind enough to mention we last year
passed the wall street journal is the
biggest business publication period in
the world which is great we're now red
and thank you write in something like a
hundred countries we had seven
international editions including
Australia and our team is now 250 people
we have an office downtown been just an
incredible privilege to watch the
company grow and so forth so lots of
talk about so going back to amazon if
that was the question well so i need a
shower yeah sorry i just wanted because
i want to give you a picture because
yeah i'm sure maybe little things have
crept through but the full picture
because it certainly has been a an
unusual career path is what i would say
folks at the company who are just out of
school asked me like what's your career
advice and my first career advice is
don't try to mimic my career trajectory
because it is bizarre in many ways and
we can get into that but so with amazon
basically as you remember from the
early internet years the way
technologies proliferate in the
awareness of them you find a small group
that gets very inspired by a new
technology prices get bid up around the
people who are capitalizing that
technology these prices look crazy to
people who don't understand the
technology haven't heard the stories
that folks inside have heard and so we
go always go through this period in the
press where the press on the outside is
just golfing at these obviously
ludicrous valuations that an inside
investors are paying amazon was a
classic case of that when it went public
would not have no profit of course
because it's never had profit until last
night very nice in one division which
now I know Jeff one is the prices and
eliminate the profit because that's what
they do and that's brilliant by the way
ignore all people who say that
businesses should make money forget it
just reinvest the money and you can
become amazon and Wall Street will
forgive you for that they're fine amazon
stock price is good but anyway so amazon
was incredibly controversial lots of
people were calling for it's going to go
out of business it's terrible it's just
a bookstore it's worth more than Barnes
and Noble and you were the CEO of
barnesandnoble.com at that point looking
up at the ludicrous amazon valuation so
basically I was doing the conservative
thing which was well raise my price
target ten to fifteen percent above the
current price love amazon so forth and
finally one of the folks on our
institutional sales force like Henry
look I'm sick of you getting up every
morning and say you don't kind of like
Amazon ten to fifteen percent upside
like what do you really think it can do
what's it's really worth and so I
fiddled with my spreadsheet for a couple
of days back of an airplane coming back
from Houston i remember it said look
like if the world evolves the way we
think it can evolve this stock would be
worth five hundred dollars and i
computed that a few different ways it
was then trading it but i think it gone
from 90 to about 200 and so i just went
out and said we'll do be a little more
conservative than that so it's okay
price target 400 and by the way that's
no different from raising a price target
on a twenty-dollar stock 240 but because
it had gotten to 200 and it had another
zero
one went crazy and so suddenly lots of
excitement around that fortunately that
target played out for a little while it
went to something like 550 which was
nice and then it went down to six I
believe that about ninety-eight percent
in NATO was going to go out of business
it was always a terrible idea and
anybody who liked it was an idiot and
all that stuff I wrote it down I
actually had my own money where my mouth
was so I'm so forth Jesus go wrong happy
yes I still own a great long-term
investment so anyway that was the Amazon
story can I don't want to dwell too much
on the past because it was a long time
ago but it's an amazing time we both
went through it the cycle up was
euphoric the cycle down was quick and
brutal what was that like for it I know
you were getting investigated at the
time and eventually that's so far yeah
but you don't want the up and down that
bust you know did you realize the
euphoria on the up and and what was the
best like for you going down yes so so I
spent my life there's this like family
lore around me apparently some great
grandfather somewhere was riding the
Siberian Express a railway during the
19th 29 crash and he went from being a
mogul to penniless and this kind of
permeated my family growing up being
back the glory days and so forth so in
the 1990s when I went to Wall Street I
used to ask a lot of people because you
would hear old-timers say like I was
just building up to be a huge bubble and
so I would ask people especially toward
the late nineties you is this another
bubble are we in the 1920s again and
everyone's like no it's not we have
great accounting now and the SEC and
everybody's smart and so for to know
it's not like the 1920s of course it was
worse than the 1920s and and so the big
lesson for me was first of all everyone
says now oh they were just such idiots
in the 1990s that's actually some of us
were I plead guilty to idiocy but it's
not that we weren't talking about the
fact that it was probably a bubble in
fact a lot of us were and the question
is what decisions you make in the
meantime and when is it going to end and
and so forth and so nobody knew those
questions it'll lasted a hell of a lot
longer than most people in the 90s
thought it would
it ended suddenly over a period of a
year and suddenly there was this
wreckage everywhere but we did have a
good sense that it was probably going to
end sometime and good companies would
come through it and others would not and
the ratio is about what we expected I
think something like half of companies
probably just disappeared and and others
sort of merged and some have come out of
it well but yeah the bus the backlash is
it's intense and they're always a
regulatory backlash which is something
that I only learned after the bubble i
read john kenneth galbraith book about
financial bubbles it's just part of the
pattern it's when stuff gets changed
it's the same thing that happened after
Enron blew up and after the financial
crisis we then have all these new laws
this is what happens everybody gets
angry they want changes you get some
changes then we launch into the next
bubble cycle but to be clear what is
happening right now is nothing like the
1990s there are echoes of it but it is
still a money much as in technology a
much distant echo technology has always
been cyclical I think we are getting to
the end of this cycle there will be a
drawdown in which all of the folks who
are being lionized as geniuses now and
all the money raining from the sky on
anyone who has an even remotely
interesting idea will stop lots of
companies will go broke money will be
much harder to raise and we will go
through a tough period for a while but
there are real companies out there with
absolutely astounding fundamentals that
are worth a ton of money and a lot of
them will get through it and the changes
that the internet is still bringing to
the world economy are unbelievably
profound so the idea that this is all
hallucination is crazy the cycle will
end at some point valuations will get
hammered and then we will start the
process again we've gone through about
four of these cycles since the 1980s so
we're going to get back to this in a
little more detail towards the end okay
I'm gonna buy shorter answers I will
just point out that Castlight health did
go public at twelve million dollars in
revenue and had a 1.4 billion dollar
valuation the first day and that seems a
little out of whack to me everyone is
excited about the future of digital
health care
there could be some many bubbles with
their plenty there's going to be carnage
everywhere I'm not trying to suggest
otherwise the question and also is it as
total as the wreckage in the 1990s and
and the answer is we're not a couple
more years of this at this glide slope
up yes then you can start saying okay
whoa it's really like the end okay I
want to go back for a minute to sort of
merrill lynch stuff and mr. Spitzer just
for a moment because I don't think you
were totally fair I think you know
Spitzer was coming after Merrill Lynch
you were part of it but it was a bigger
play right and Merrill Lynch got find a
lot of money a lot of money hundreds of
millions of dollars as did the industry
i was just Merrill yeah so you you
weren't being isolated in that oh I
would've actually isolate it well it
wrote some very colorful emails that
made wonderful in evidence so I have to
ask you because I don't know if this is
true or not but obviously Merrill paid a
lot of money Lonnie Stefan's was the
vice chairman of Merrill at the time I
believe and several years later mr.
Spitzer was under his own investigation
and there was some rumor that mr.
Stefan's might have hired a p.i and
leaked it to the press hmm any truth I
have no idea it's a good story though
right that was certainly even could have
been payback it was certainly an
interesting story to see pop up on my
screen at business insider when it came
out I must say and at that point you
know again to basically bear markets for
Wall Street or bull markets for
regulators and lawyers we saw this Rudy
Giuliani Eliot Spitzer capitalized on it
marvelously people were really talking
about him being a president I mean he
was just glowing in the public and then
suddenly just a fantastic fall and I
should say that though but I need to
finish the story because this was all 15
years ago for me so Eliot Spitzer and I
are now kind of friends I mean it may be
there's kind of the two just brace guys
go off and have lunch one once in a
while but we had lunch recently you know
talk about his kids and what he's doing
now and same thing for me it's a little
weird but life is long one of the things
that somebody told me I was like a
friend of mine is a disaster PR person
and I called him in the middle of the
absolute global thumping that I was
received and it was it was unbelievably
intense for a little while and I
basically should look you know I don't
mean to drag professional stuff in to
this but like is there anything that I
can do and he basically said no you
can't say anything because you're in the
middle of legal stuff so you can't
protest and you can't say anything and
wouldn't help anyway because those were
some pretty colorful emails and people
are really pissed off and so it doesn't
matter he said the good news is just
ride it out eventually it will become
this story of what happened along ago
play a long game and then the example
that he used which is very interesting
you may not remember this but back when
Prince Charles who's with Diana the now
future Queen of England Prince Charles
the white if I believe named Camilla the
press hated her every day is a story
about the rottweiler and how awful she
is and she's breaking up this storybook
marriage and we hate her we hate her
hate her he said notice she never said
anything ever and then 10 years later
the press has come around they want her
to be queen so he's basically message
like ride it up and that's incredibly
hard to do when you have basically been
out there trying to be very forthright
with people that's why people actually
like me in the 90s was gone CNBC I would
speak in normal language I wouldn't talk
about edad and stuff like that it would
ever just speak normally and say this is
what could happen amazon people like
that I was optimistic that helped the
stocks were going up but I suddenly
couldn't say anything I had it ball Sox
shoved in my mouth and I was thrown some
black back closet with duct tape around
my head and it was basically just kick
Henry for two years and fortunately
again he was right you play a long game
and come through it I still anytime I
write something that somebody doesn't
like they post Spitzer's press release
on the site and I get it in my email so
it's never going to go away but you do
in fact you can you can go through it
okay I think I'd love you to focus on
this a little more which is the
resurrection because many people go
through traumatic things not all of them
bounce back and build a number one
in their category so that transition for
you and that transformation for other
entrepreneurs and other people in your
personal lives is really important that
resilience so there must have been a
moment that was your nadir or sort of a
week or two or three that you hit bottom
somehow you came up bottom and are here
today with an amazing story so talk
about the bottom because we're going to
talk about the app on the other so I'll
talk about the first up and I should say
that when I was going up and it was a
very spectacular meteoric rise that was
just mainly about me being in the right
place at the right time and again making
the Amazon call I got a lot of tension
happily it worked out which a lot of my
other calls did not that helped there
were lots of little stories at the time
there was a tense interest in the
internet and and so forth so the fame
which I was not seeking came very easily
and what I would liken it to is I was
out there paddling around on a normal
surf day waiting for surf board and nice
three-foot waves and it's cool i'm doing
my job and then suddenly a hundred foot
monster wave comes along and i was able
to stay on the board and i was actually
proud of that it did the best job that I
could under the circumstances it worked
out very well for me challenging working
around the clock huge demands and things
like that but I felt pretty good like I
had tried as hard as I could to manage
all the different conflicts and so forth
and learned quickly about being this big
public figure and how to speak carefully
and and so much with it was very fast I
was only an analyst for five years which
I look back now that is the defining
part of my life I've actually been doing
business inside our way longer than I
was an analyst so it happened but some
people when they go through that they
kind of believe all the press around
them I didn't I didn't mind it
particularly but I wasn't like oh my god
the Philadelphia Inquirer just wrote a
profile of me i am so great I never
really got it I said Wow right place
right time do the best you can so forth
so when it all reversed and I was
getting crushed I at least didn't have
to also face the fact that I had been
diluted about myself while things were
going well I always felt I owe a i was
riding this huge wave i managed to stay
on the board and
I hit some major league rocks and I have
been splatted beyond belief what can I
do so forth at that navier-- and it
sucked I would I just spaced there a
moment later to him where I mean
literally like I would walk out of my
door and I would their new york times is
working on another story about you and
and so forth and it's going to smell
story and do you want to contribute i
can't contributor can't say anything i
can't even defend myself because we're
in this legal thing so far the firm's
handling all that and then it becomes a
front-page thing and I step over it as i
leave my apartment in the morning it's
like oh my goodness the hometown paper
trashes me again I mean it got to that
level every acquaintance I had who was
an acquaintance because of where I was
they wouldn't talk to me anymore the
good news is my core friends thought it
was a bunch of BS and they were right
there for me and my wife and my family
and what I realized most importantly
it's like this is just it is a
professional disaster but that's it and
there are so many things that are so
much worse than that couple of weeks ago
the son of a friend of mine was killed
in a plane crash that is actually a
tragedy it is something you it's just a
completely different order of things so
for me I looked around like I didn't
lose half my brain in a car crash I can
still talk I can still write this has
been an amazing experience maybe I can
use it in some way it has definitely
made me smarter about the world I've
learned things okay I'm going to spend
the rest of my professional life trying
to earn back some of the trust that was
just destroyed because it was a huge
privilege to have it in the 1990s I
didn't go seeking it but I had it but
try to earn it back I understand that a
lot of people will never give me that
chance but the ones that will every day
I'm going to try to rebuild that and
that's what started and in the beginning
with the egg throwing and rock throwing
and fruit throwing was quite intense but
and it still is occasionally comes up
but just every day trying to effectively
regain the trust that I had lost and yes
I don't know I'm not sure
what it was but there was definitely
something I just wasn't going to quit on
that and I was going to try to do
something of value and and fortunately
you know ultimately it's like if I had
remain in the securities industry I
probably would've gone to a hedge fund
that would have been the easy route I
stopped to write a book and I wrote a
book but of course legally can't publish
it or couldn't maybe eventually someday
it's still sitting there on the shelf
but I probably would've gone to a hedge
fund I would've been the easiest route
to go hedge fund you know good smart
work it's fun make tons of money kind of
easy and so forth but I was actually
forced to do this other thing and now
i'm so happy that i was forced to
because every day it's just so creative
and fun and it's such a privilege as a
new medium you get to figure out how it
works and tell stories ultimately
fundamentally as illustrated by what i
did when i got out of school I'm a
storyteller that's what I do and so now
come back this is actually way better
for me and so ultimately it did work out
well although again I wouldn't have
planned it better okay so let's focus on
the positive just the ramp up what was
what was the original idea so the
original idea was look there's this new
medium if you go back through the
history of media what happens when
there's a new medium is existing media
site whoa it's a new medium it's a green
field we're going to just take what we
do and shove it into the new medium and
we're going to be heroes so if you go
back to the beginning of TV the first TV
news brought news broadcasts or some
dude reading a newspaper in front of a
microphone okay well that's that's not
completely awful but maybe you can do
better like pictures they're actually
worth a thousand words and in fact great
video of exciting stuff is worth way
more than that so maybe we can do
different things in television that we
can't do in print and so this incredible
new medium of TV evolved TV journalism
is so different from newspaper
journalism different business model
different pay scales way more evolved
into something and much much more
influential because it turns out that
actually it's easier to watch TV then
read and you can learn things you can't
learn an article and so forth although
they didn't teach me that at Yale but it
became clear that Fox News is
actually a lot more influential than a
lot of the publications I was raised to
think were the absolute pinnacle of
journalism so anyway that about so we
said the same thing is going to happen
in digital we just got to figure it out
because we know that just posting a
newspaper online or putting a TV network
online doesn't work the missus model
doesn't work it's not what people want
they don't want to watch TV online they
want these new things so so what he's
working what do we look at we looked at
drudge which was killing it even then we
looked at Gawker Media which was killing
it Huffington Post which was killing it
we said okay these guys are on the trail
of what digital journalism is going to
look like and so we experimented
experimenting expanded we didn't try to
jam newspaper peg in the hole we just
said figure out what works lots of
boneheaded ideas but fortunately some of
them worked out and we just kept
doubling down on the ones that worked
out and and ultimately we still every
day we come in to serve our readers
we're the new generation of leaders
they're almost a hundred percent digital
they want their stories to be short
quick illustrative yes we love our three
thousand word New York or articles
sometimes but you know during a busy day
on this kind of hard to read them so
maybe a quick synopsis of that or
bullets or maybe on the weekend a super
long one we have published twenty five
thousand word stories when it's
warranted we can do that but short
videos long videos you can do pretty
much anything but you just got to figure
out you know what is it that people want
what will they want to consume what do
they care about we have these incredible
analytics that show us what people are
reading what they're interested in so
every day we come in we try to serve our
readers and that has been a huge
advantage is a lot of our competitors
have the incredible challenge of having
to put out a world-class newspaper every
day which in case there's any question
is extremely difficult and to have to do
that and to compete with all these
upstarts in digital it's just immensely
difficult and Jeff Bezos took me down
the Washington Post last year met with
the editor team it just incredible
incredibly impressed and a new sense of
just how hard it was for them to put out
this amazing newspaper and have this
website that's supposed to be competing
with BuzzFeed and Huffington Post and
all these other guys who just do that
but long-winded answer which seems to be
the only kind I'm capable of warning we
are experimenting every day to figure
out what works in this medium the
industry is still figuring it out but
we're starting to get a good sense of
what these companies can look like 10 to
20 years down the road and hopefully
we'll continue to have you all read us
occasionally and continue to get better
so let's let dive a little deeper into
that now you've gone from zero to number
one in seven years eight years you've
crushed the traditional media companies
why can't a traditional media company
compete in this market you touched us a
little bit but it's important to dive in
a little deeper nobody has crushed
anybody yes oh I coming number one in
seven years baby is doing just fine and
for ten years when I finally realized
how wrong I was about the death of TV
was when I went on The Today Show one
morning and before the today show you
get the makeup guy and everybody has a
makeup guy but then there was a dude at
the Today Show who does nothing but
steam suits and roll lint off suits and
I said oh if you can afford this guy you
are in great shape for a long time
there's just colossal amounts of money
in television so the death of television
is going to take a long long long long
time it's probably ultimately going to
look like the death of print which if
you are at the New York Times New York
Times has a wonderful digital business
four hundred million dollars a year that
would support eight hundred top-notch
excellent journalists we would be so
stoked to have the New York Times
digital business someday that would be
amazing so nobody is crushing anybody
except in this readership metric which
hopefully foretells long-term success as
we add the business to it we add more
and more people and so forth and now
I've is all preamble what was the
question that you have question who has
we did it why can't the traditional
media guys how come they didn't do it
anybody can anybody can do anything but
focus matters and works and again it to
me asking the question like well why
can't the New York Times just do that
they can but it digital is as different
from
and television as print and television
are from each other so the same question
would be why didn't the New York Times
just make CNN and part of the answers
will allow to own networks and to
markets and newspapers and so forth for
regulatory reasons but you can see the
challenge it's actually fundamentally
different at a very profound level it's
the same thing for digital it's a
different editorial approach it's
different storytelling formats it's a
different speed it's a very different
business model it's a different training
for the journalists there are a thousand
little differences but they add up to
something very different and when you've
got ninety percent of the smartest
people in the building and there are
brilliant people in that building
focused on putting out a world-class
newspaper every day and the other ten
percent are second-class citizens who
whose ultimate hope is that someday
someone at the paper will realize that
they're talented enough to be put into
print that's the problem at our shop
every brain in the building is focused
on making digital as good as it can be
and we have so far to go in terms of how
much better we can get we're good
ultimately we want to be excellent but
that sense of focus on something that is
different difficult makes a huge
difference which why Amazon succeeded
they didn't also have to run this
colossal store network which is also
incredibly different difficult they were
just able to focus on Commerce and
another thing Bezos talk to me he was an
investor on whether you mentioned I'm
not just dropping his name for the hell
they actually i think is he you know he
said like it was more than a decade
before they could begin to say okay are
there other things that we can do it was
that hard to build and figure out
ecommerce and and even now every year it
still we got to get x % better x %
better x % better and that level of
focus makes all the difference okay so
for the entrepreneurs in the room I'd
love to focus on your transition from
entrepreneur to CEO from three employees
working in an elevator shaft to 175
employees and managing people and not
just focusing on the product every day
but also running a business raising
money dealing with shareholders success
so how's that transition been so I've
been CEO from the first day I was the
first employee is CEO and founder and
all that stuff so it's been a very
gradual transition basically the first
thing they should teach you in CEO
school if they haven't is you got to
figure out what you're good at and you
gotta hire people who are great at
everything else stop doing the stuff
that you're bad at that you don't like
find someone who loves it who's great at
it and delegate the hell out of them i
pinged another friend of mine has been
incredibly successful he's very speaks
in few words but they just echo in your
head forever with their penis and
profoundness said I'm a CEO now what do
I do I mean the email came back it said
hire great people and get out of the way
period so I have learned to do that and
what I am good at is the editorial stuff
storytelling new medium how do we
experiment what's the best way to tell
that story what are the readers like so
forth what am I not as good at
everything else I do like strategy I I
like the business because I came from
The Wall Street an analysis I studied
businesses for a while so I want to make
sure we have the business model that
works when I go out on the advertising
side what do i do am i selling know i
suck at that we have somebody who's
great at that what i do is talk about
digital journalism and media what we've
learned about facebook and so forth and
then our wonderful sales team goes in it
does that the fifth higher at the
company was also a Yale graduate Julie
Hansen she's the president of the
company she is great at managing my
management philosophy when I came it was
like just do it well it's like well
that's not actually akan duty is not I'm
very there are other better ways of
managing let's put it that way so she's
very good at that she's very patient so
forth and so she learned all that she's
very organized she runs the company she
make sure we hit our numbers and and so
forth so I focus on editorial and I do
what I'm doing today which is go out and
talk about the great future of digital
journalism and that's the key and and
ultimately as companies get bigger as
you know you always have to ask yourself
every year or so as you get bigger
it's hard to be world class at anything
and there are CEOs of companies who
they're just world-class CEOs and they
lead thousands of people and you do have
to ask yourself I ask myself all the
time and the board asks me all the time
you know are you still the guy or should
we get a CEO and you can be mr.
editorial storyteller and and thus far
it is I have felt a passionate thing to
say nope I want to do that and can i
drop his name again sure one of the
advice the Jeff gave me he said look
because i think i got like the guys soon
me once so we got to be careful sorry
but McKenzie his wife worked for me as
an intern there we go so it's all good
so I said Jeff like you know this is
question like should I not be CEO
anymore and so forth and he listened and
he is it's just so astoundingly smart
like everyone and everyone is smart we
meet smart people all day it's like
another level of smart because it's not
quick with the answer he's thought about
everything and he said look I beseech
you whatever you do please be CEO and I
said why that's an unusual thing to hear
and he said scale with the company learn
how to do it but if you delegate that if
you hire somebody else to do that here's
what will happen that person will be
very strong they would have to be to be
able to do it they will come in they
will start making little decisions you
will say well I know that's not right
but I got to give him the room to make a
decision so forth I got a rear ear out
the wiring of the company so that they
realize who's really in charge now and
so let him do it he said every day
without knowing it you make hundreds of
little course corrections around this
whole building the sustainable digital
journalism model if you start to lose
that somebody else makes those decisions
who doesn't understand the business as
well as you do in six months two years
down the road we are hundreds of miles
off course so just stick with it scale
with the company that doesn't mean you
can always do it like if you don't scale
with the company companies got to change
Steve Jobs should have been fired from
Apple there's this big story now oh what
a bunch of idiots an apple they fired
Steve Jobs the biggest dumbest decision
in Maine in business history not true go
back to the history Steve Jobs was a
complete disruptive egomaniac lunatic
who could not ship a product the company
would have just splattered on the rocks
if they hadn't fired Steve Jobs he went
off into the wilderness he learned he
came back and then he was the genius
steve jobs that we know about that but
so you have to scale with the company
but that whole passionate founder
business thing ultimately turns out does
translate well to leadership and and
just ask mark zuckerberg I mean that guy
just laser-focused from the beginning
from his dorm room on what facebook
could become we couldn't have just
replaced himself with a manager facebook
is what it is today because he stayed
there and then he hired Cheryl and that
is it turned out to be a very good
combination so I'd like to dissect this
a bit in case it wasn't clear because
something really important happened in
what you said which is you play
different roles in the company some days
your shareholder and thinking about the
company and the value some days you're
CEO well every day your CEO but you
change your approach if you're
monochromatic and just have one approach
that's when you can follow in to have
some pitfalls but you have to have
multiple personalities to some extent
multiple perspectives to be successful
you agree you have to be flexible and
learn all the time and I have learned a
huge amount over eight years and if
things continue as they are and we get
bigger that will be I will have to
continue to learn it changes all the
time or global organization now you have
to speak very differently to hundreds of
people then to three people at the
loading dock you just say do this do
that very easy it changes and you do
have to learn and there are different
pieces of it and one of the things that
is push back to me a lot by our
excellent manager president is you got
to give people more room don't just
don't just tell them what to do let them
come to you you've got to and and so
that's another thing that I'm learning
but but many things will go into that
okay let's look forward a little bit
where are we in the cycle well how do we
evaluate what today is going to happen
tech cycles usually lasts seven to ten
years you go back to the early 80s
just sort of track them and you can look
at venture capital flows seven to ten
years and then they collapse and come
down thirty percent or something like
that or in the case of the bubble vastly
lower than that and they start building
again so we're in about year seven or
eight now so when when are we going to
turn I don't know it could be now it
could be happening right now and there's
some very crazy things going on silicon
valley I mean money is literally falling
from the sky like every day Oh some dog
bone delivery service raises 30 million
it's like wow I remember when it was
like 30 billion only went to the guy who
wanted to launch a satellite and now
some dog bone delivery service just gets
30 million cover that how much did
amazon raised in the IPO wasn't was
maybe fifth out fight we're companies
use to go public way way earlier yeah
and it's over the amazon was only worth
500 million like the dog bone delivery
service was probably valley dat 500
minute so that's not going to last and
suddenly we're going to go into this
period where it's much much much harder
to raise money but again we could be
starting to happen now might be a year
or two out I don't think it goes much
longer than that yeah am i stupid to be
buying a Bitcoin a week oh no I do it so
bitcoin is it's a binary bed it could be
worth a fraction of a penny or it could
be worth a million ultimately per
bitcoin if it becomes adopted as a
worldwide currency and so forth you
could be good great investment so you
just got to look at the binary and the
odds actually he could lose everything
and there's a decent chance of that but
he would look like a complete idiot and
is somebody who shorted Continental
Airlines remember them back in like 17
incarnations ago explain to me is like
you can make just as much money shorting
a one-dollar stock that's about to go
bankrupt as you can shorting 150 dollar
super overvalued company that might go
to 20 in fact you could make more you
still make ninety-nine point nine
percent but if bitcoins goes to zero all
you can lose is all of your money one
hundred percent i and that's fine
hundred percent so k if it goes to a
million move dad is what's called an
asymmetric return and a gambler sees
that and says I like it give me lots and
lots of those bets
and so I think it's a reasonable debt
I'm gonna buy a Bitcoin or two and we
just for the hell direct deposit every
week about a fully ready average down no
no this take some flame honey move the
chips over and forget about it 50 years
I was interesting probably going off the
10 and a few sounds but taringa
yesterday which is the number 22
facebook at latin america announced that
they would actually give bitcoins to
users to generate content so they're
compensating people to generate content
on their social network is that a model
for the future whether it's Bitcoin or
something else I'd gathered I mean I
paying people for content is reasonable
and the Bitcoin isn't it doesn't know
what they're doing yeah so sure I mean I
love the social networks gonna have a
business model it survives Facebook
doesn't pay anybody for content 1.4
billion users so that's a pretty good
model you guys if you have some
questions we've got about five minutes
left so I'm happy to look to the
audience and if hands pop up one popped
up
for future and you know can they get
there
just
can you repeat it I question is are
there like are there going to be
platforms that are different than the
platforms we have today like Facebook
and the social networks presumably that
are different in the future i can say
with 100-percent certainly absolutely I
don't know what they are I do not spend
my time now talking to ventric really
forward-looking venture capitalists is
what's next I mean some of the things
that I hear about this actually goes to
the health care company of the folks who
do that they look five to ten years out
they don't chase what's happen a health
care is one of the big opportunities
bitcoins another and not Bitcoin but the
blockchain like people think okay that
thing could be interred at could be a
platform for all sorts of things so
that's another thing but like a new
social network that's pretty much five
years ago and so that lots are still
launching but very hard to gain traction
and and so forth so I don't
unfortunately not a good I can't give
you a good answer because I don't spend
my time doing that anymore but go ahead
i push this worthlessness facebook now
trying to get a location works case
model is their high quality with an
audience but so maybe there's a setting
like wear masks
hmm so the whole journalism industry is
collectively freaking out because
Facebook which sends a lot of readers is
now talking about hey we want your
content in Facebook and especially the
traditional guys like oh no we must
control everything and Facebook's the
devil except we love the millions of
people you send us every day and so
forth so the big question about that I
think actually Facebook what they
actually do want to do is improve the
experience I think that's great they are
already doing in the video facebook
launched video year or two ago our
facebook video views are just exploding
because we are taking video and we are
sending it to Facebook and Facebook is
integrating it into the experience and
that's the way it's working for BuzzFeed
and many others and it is a much better
experience they figured out very nice
way to do it so is there an analogue for
print or text or photos to do that and
live on Facebook I think absolutely I
think we will get there to me it's
really except for facebook is huge and
very dominance like having a cable
company with fifty percent of the market
it's similar to the cable analogy which
is if you have a TV network in order to
get it in front of people's eyeballs you
have to do a deal with a TV distributor
which is a cable network that's all
Facebook is and the way those deals work
is ok we'll take your network maybe
we'll pay you directly for it maybe
we'll give you a couple of ads per hour
there has to be a way that publishers
get paid we need to be able to pay our
journalists and Facebook's moving toward
that they've just started a video
program that'll do that so I feel okay
about it I don't and in part because his
facebook has pointed out to me it's like
you know don't mean to insult you but
like wrap up the entire content industry
the marketing budget for the entire
industry it's a 15-percent of Procter
and Gamble one actual big advertiser so
we don't want to put you out of business
would like what you're doing for us
terms of native advertising I think
we're just in the beginning of really
figuring out what that looks like and if
you look at all other media TV ads are
native to television they're just many
versions of the stories that we're
watching it used to be the soap thing
right on the front of the thing they
didn't have ads then
figured out okay how to do this and it
worked so that's what the industry is
still doing we're figuring out what's
the right format for telling stories how
do we do it native is a good step toward
that we're doing some of that and and so
ultimately I think that will continue to
grow but I think it's just a way to
think about it we're still experimenting
people will always want great stories
and the storytellers will always have to
figure out have to get how to get paid
in some way and there will be
advertising it's just a question of how
and ten years it'll be much much clearer
okay my goal for this was to get through
40 minutes with Henry and not use the
word slideshow or listicle and we did
that I think so I've achieved my goal is
listicle a word I think it is let's do
those people love lists whoa so we could
have talked for hours and it would've
been really fun but we had 40 minutes
and hopefully you got something out of
it so please give a big round of
applause